majority of consumers they don't know
what it means to make a garment you see
a garment on Iraq and you just assume
it's made by machines they have no idea
that factories exist in Manhattan
they just think fashion and they think
glamour they think fashion shows what
they don't understand is the nitty
gritty
we're here at Johnny's fashion studio
which is a development and production
studio in I guess more dirtier words at
the garment factory my name is Johnny
I'm work here almost 30 years in New
York City my name is Joanne Kim I'm just
kind of following the footsteps of my
father
we start out with clients who come in
with some rough sketches we have our
initial consultation to discuss what is
it about this jacket that you want to
see come to life and from that we'll
make our first pattern a pattern is like
the puzzle piece that ends up getting
cut and sewn our cutter will take that
on top of the fabric and we'll go into
cutting the actual fabric from there
it's ready to go into sewing we've got a
team of New York City's best stores and
we've got them on the machine
they've been with Johnny for the last
ten years and she's trained them from
the beginning we'll go through fittings
adjustments until we finally come up
with the final garment and the hopes is
that it's exactly what they expected if
we see one of those brands go from 30
units a season to 3,000 units a season
we'll adapt
one client that Johnny's worked with in
the past is Ann Taylor they used to like
more than ten Factory in New York City
and when was that what you 1992-93 or
some day
so after there they moved to China or
somewhere take about notice like couple
months on me so I have like more than
200 employer so we lost the job and lost
the business so we got a hard time there
are businesses under my command can
indeed alyssa hannon gallon eb
convenience a gusto para que tenga hamid
I agree Sam will great idea Sharon go
low
Sarang Sarang go low back yourself woman
the presence of Albert Hall streets at
that
right now the garment district in
general does a lot of smaller brands a
lot of smaller production because
anything mass-market anything bigger is
happening overseas we survive by taking
on these younger brands we're hoping
that those small brands become the big
brands and they stay in the garment
district they stay in New York and they
stay with us because then once they grow
we can grow he's been doing this for 30
years and he doesn't always get invited
to the fashion shows I'm just like
factory man I'm like what when I see
their you know good product I'm happy
where hasn't for me it's not enough I
need money